alexander der große die lichtgestalt den
alten griechenland
der königssohn aus dem abgelegenen
makedonien wird zum größten eroberer
aller zeiten
damit hat niemand gerechnet damit dass
jemand versucht die ganze welt richtig
konkret zu erobern
und zweitens dass auch noch fast
gelingen würde
mit 16 er nennt ihn sein vater zum
mitregenten die zeiten sind unruhig ein
attentat sichert ihm die königskrone
und seine bündnispartner machen
alexander zum mächtigsten mann
griechenlands
sein feldzug gegen könig darius den
persischen weltherrscher leicht dem
kampf zwischen david gegen goliath
doch wie 18 sein held aus der sage ist
alexander fest entschlossen den griechen
den sieg zu bringen
es gibt nur wenige einzelnen menschen
die die geschichte so stark beeinflusst
haben die alexander der große
es ist frühling als alexander die
meerenge zwischen europa und der
heutigen türkei überquert mit 37.000
soldaten aus ganz griechenland
[Musik]
der marke donau hat einen klaren auftrag
seines erfolgs männer und er sollen die
griechischen kolonien von den persern
befreien
sein erster weg führt alexander nach
troja am ehrengrab von achill lässt er
seine waffen wein und er bringt ein
opfer dar
seit der kindheit ist der furchtloser
held aus der ilias alexanders
leuchtendes vorbild an achilles ruhm
will er sich messen seine taten sogar
noch übertreffen
der befreiungskrieg bietet die passende
gelegenheit nur braucht der junge könig
auch den schutz der götter durch ihren
segen wird der rachefeldzug gegen die
perser zur heiligen mission
bislang ist es aber noch niemandem
gelungen die weltmacht in die knie zu
zwingen
schon auf ihrem vormarsch durch
besetztes gebiet versucht eine
streitmacht die eindringlinge mit gewalt
zu stoppen
vergeblich 334 vor christus führt
alexander seine männer am fluss grau
nikos zum ersten sieg
vom persischen hof in babylon hat man
den angreifer aus makedonien offenbar
unterschätzt nicht das starke reichs her
sondern eine armee aus berufssoldaten es
dem feind entgegen getreten
gross könig darius hat auf sie vertraut
ein fehler wie sich herausstellt
mein könig
ich bitte um vergebung für die schlechte
nachricht überbringen muss alexander hat
gesiegt wie ist das möglich
alexander zwar viel weniger soldaten als
wir aber er geht praktisch äußerst
geschickt vor und das nicht nur auf dem
schlachtfeld
wie meinst du das er verspricht eine
demokratische verfassung nach dem
vorbild athens für jede stadt die ihn
kampflos die tore öffnet und er
verspricht allen dass sie dir keinen
tribut mehr zahlen müssen
ist das so
ich habe gehört er abstellen makedonien
selbst wie einen könig von wegen der
herrschaft des volkes das ist alles
unsinn
also was will er wirklich die griechen
wollen rache nehmen für die zerstörung
athens und die besetzung kleinasiens
alexander aber will noch mehr
und was
macht
wir meinen thron so ist es du solltest
die verteidigung seines reiches nicht
länger seinen vasallen überlassen wer
könnte unser er besser führen als du
selbst
er wird es bereuen dass er den schoß
seiner mutter verlassen hat
sammle unsere truppe sagt ihnen ihr
könig zieht in den krieg
die macht des perserkönig es reicht von
den grenzen griechenlands und dem alten
ägypten bis weit nach osten über den
hindukusch bis ins ferne indien
ans ende der damals bekannten weg
sein imperium umfasst drei kontinente
mitten im herzen des reichs liegt
persepolis im süden des heutigen iran
persepolis ist zugleich auch das
religiöse zentrum der perser selbst noch
über 2000 jahren vermitteln die paläste
und tempel noch immer einen eindruck von
der machtfülle ihrer erbauer
der jetzt zeigen die vielen
nationalitäten des riesenreichs
insgesamt 28 punkte
[Musik]
darunter syrer ägypter bei colonia
griechen inder und araber sie alle sind
angetreten um dem regenten zum
neujahrsfest kostbare geschenke zu
bringen
für viele sind die perserin vorbild sie
haben eine politische ordnung aufgebaut
die ein friedliches zusammenleben der
länder ermöglicht
doch es gibt auch widerstand gegen die
fremdbestimmung auch von den
griechischen kolonien vor ihnen kann
alexander fast immer als befreier
aufträgen
[Musik]
in wenigen monaten nimmt der marke krone
die wichtigsten küstenstädte ein und er
kontrolliert bereits weite teile der
heutigen türkei als er in gordion sein
winterquartier aufschlägt
im tempel bestaunt er den vielgerühmten
wagen des früheren königs cord use
und das soll der wagen eines könig sein
es heißt er gehörte cottbus im könig der
früher als die folge ein könig gesucht
haben befahl ihnen das orakel den ersten
mann zu wählen der ihnen auf einem wagen
begegnet und was war zufällig georgius
so schnell wird man hier also könig ja
aber das ist noch nicht die ganze
geschichte
siehst du den knoten da was ist damit
es heißt wem es gelingt diesen knoten zu
lösen mit herrscher über das gesamte
perserreich
der knoten scheint weder anfang noch
ende zu haben
die geschichte vom gordischen knoten ist
nur eine legende und eine geschickte
propaganda maßnahme
diese sache mit dem schwert ich war die
spricht ja nun wirklich für sich sagt
alexander ich mache das auf meine
methode
alle leute sind gescheitert aber ich
zeige ihnen wie man das macht mit der
befreiung der griechischen kolonien ist
es nicht getan
alexander ist versessen darauf daraus
vom thron zu stürzen der versammelten
reichs er im heutigen grenzgebiet
zwischen türkei und syrien
auch alexander setzt seine armee in
bewegung
doch beide streitkräfte ziehen
aneinander vorbei ohne sich zu bemerken
plötzlich stehen die perser im rücken
und versperren ihnen den fluchtweg ins
haus kommt es zur offenen schlacht
der könig aus makedonien gegen darius
den mächtigsten mann der welt und gegen
mehr als 70.000 krieger männer der feind
steht zwischen uns und unsere heimat
wir werden siegen oder untergehen wenn
ein rückzug ist ausgeschlossen
doch lasst euch nicht vom clans und der
größe unseres gegners plätzen
ich sehe was ihr seht doch keiner von
euch sieht es mit meinen augen sehr groß
könig unterschätzt uns also habt mut
denn das ist nicht das erste mal dass
wir vor einer übermacht stehen und es
ist nicht das letzte mal dass wir sie
[Applaus]
gross könig darius glaubt an ein
leichtes spiel
er baut auf die zahlenmäßige
überlegenheit adamy
der anführer der makedonien ist vor
allem wagemutig und setzt auf die
schnelligkeit seiner karte
[Applaus]
333 bei estos keilerei auf den berühmten
alexander sarkophag ist der kampf
nachgestellt der makedonien könig ist
der held der szene
anfangs gerät alexander zwar in
bedrängnis die mann starken perser haben
zuerst die oberhand
doch dann gelingt es den heerführer die
feindlichen linien zu durchbrechen
der eos schwebt in höchster lebensgefahr
alexander ständig die elitetruppen rund
um den groß könig kotiert
am ende bleibt darius nur die flucht die
niederlage der perser ist damit
besiegelt
die erfolge alexanders des großen ligen
zunächst daran dass er sich zum teil
überraschend verhält man könnte fast
sagen das ist wie beim fußball wer nicht
mit einer berechenbaren strategie kämpft
sondern überraschend schießt auch mehr
tore
und insofern ist alexanders strategie
eigentlich militärisch höchst riskant
scheinbar ohne überlegung immer gerade
da anzugreifen wo der gegner am
stärksten ist
noch aber ist der krieg nicht gewonnen
barrios ist noch frei er kann durch die
wüste entkommen
[Musik]
die madonnen einen weiter noch
in tyros rufen die bewohner zum kampf
auf doch wie alle die alexander
widerstand leisten werden auch sie
grausam bestraft
[Musik]
die meisten verbündeten der perser aber
feiern den makedonien als befreier auch
die ägypter empfangen ihn mit offenen
armen ihre fehde mit der weltmacht
dauert schon viel zu lange
die jeder grieche bewundert alexander
die alte hochkultur die herrschaft über
das fahrer einen reich verspricht ihm
höchstes ansehen in der heimat
nach der machtübernahme opfert der marke
den ägyptischen göttern und befragt das
orakel
er bekommt was er sich erhofft alexander
wird zum gottgleichen pharao erhoben
sein porträt wird sogar in stein
gemeißelt die bestätigung dass er der
rechtmäßige sohn des höchsten gottes
amun ray ist
bald darauf setzt der neue pharao ein
zeichen er gründet die stadt alexandria
erbaut nach griechischem vorbild
sie wird zum symbol seiner leidenschaft
in den eroberten gebieten die eigene
kultur zu verbreiten
insgesamt gründet alexander mindestens
zehn städte mit seinem namen
die metropole am mittelmeer ist seine
wichtigste und glanzvollsten dass
alexander städte gegründet hat hat
zunächst mal eine ganz besondere
bedeutung weil es zeigt ihm war es nicht
darum getan irgendetwas war kurz zu
erobern und an er wollte eine dauerhafte
herrschaft begründen und am besten
können wir das nachvollziehen bei der
gründung von alexandria hier hat er
schon im blick die gewaltigen ressourcen
die ägypten und der orient zu bieten
hatten die wirtschaftlichen ressourcen
hier wird eine große hafenstadt geplant
die ja die welt des nils das reiche
ägypten mit der welt des mittelmeers wie
ein scharnier verbindet
im frühjahr 331 vor christus ziehen die
makedonien weiter an den euphrat im
heutigen irak alexanders vormarsch ist
nicht zu stoppen
von einem friedensbündnis mit den
persern
bilder makedonien nichts wissen
alexanders armee hat in euphrat
überschritten
also hat er mein angebot nicht
angenommen
wie viele soldaten hat er unsere schwer
schätzen sie auf 40.000 mann 40.000 wir
sind im haushoch überlegen
wir können mehr als doppelt so viele
aufbieten
im september überqueren alexanders
truppen auch den tigris bei gauger
mehler erwartet ihn daraus
dieses mal hat der perserkönig das
schlachtfeld sorgfältig ausgewählt eine
weite ebene in der sein reich sher
grossaufmarsch ihren kann
den quellen zufolge übertrifft die
streitmacht der perser alles was
alexander bisher gesehen hat
das sind mehr als 100000 alexander warum
hast du das friedensangebot nicht
angenommen was hat er für seine familie
geboten alle länder westlich des euphrat
und 10.000 talente nicht mehr als wir
uns bereits genommen haben
es ist leicht etwas anzubieten was man
gar nicht mehr besetzt ich hätte sein
angebot angenommen statt jetzt alles
aufs spiel zu setzen wäre ich dope
armenien hätte ich das vielleicht auch
gemacht aber so wenig wie es zwei sorgen
am himmel geben kann so wenig kann es
zwei könige geben die über persien
herrschen und ich dachte es geht um
rache für die feigen überfälle der
perser auf unsere heimat aber darum geht
es offensichtlich längst nicht mehr
du willst es seinem toten vater beweisen
du willst größer sein als er größer sein
als alle helden griechenland wenn es da
ist
bisher haben wir nur länder befreit die
von den börsen unterworfen worden sind
hier und jetzt stehen wir in ihrem land
und unterwerfen sie lasst uns die perser
überraschen und noch heute nacht
angreifen
das wäre feige
ich will den sieg nicht stehen ich will
dass wir ehren auf kämpfen auch um auch
bei tagesanbruch die hat es gehört fragt
ihr lager auf und steht großes bevor
das super er von der eos erstreckt sich
über fünf kilometer
ein frontalangriff ist völlig
aussichtslos also startet alexander
wieder ein ablenkung
der madonna reitet zunächst parallel zu
den persischen
[Musik]
gleichzeitig setzen seine fußtruppen im
zentrum zum sturm an
die perser sollen glauben dass er über
die flügel angreifen dabei lockt
alexander seine gegner nur so lange
hinter sich her dass ihre front
auseinanderreißt
[Applaus]
der mit seiner kavallerie eine
plötzliche kehrtwende
und prescht mit seinen gefährten in die
lücke im zentrum um den perserkönig
direkt anzapfen
und auch dieses mal greift der madonnen
könig auf die strategie von nissans
zurück
unermüdlich attackieren er und seine
männer die truppen rund um den groß
könig
alexanders noch die direkte entscheidung
im kampf mann gegen mann
dollar
los
barrios überlässt seine truppen dem
schicksal sie könnten bis zum bitteren
ende
alexander mein vater brauchte ich an der
linken flanke sonst stimmen die perser
unser lager das kann doch nicht wahr
sein
durch darius erneute flucht ist die
zweite niederlage der perser besiedelt
das ist das schlusskapitel seine
herrschaft
noch auf dem schlachtfeld lässt sich
alexander zum neuen groß könig ausrufen
und seinen ruf als friedensbringer
eltern voraus
der sieg in ghana zeigte der persischen
öffentlichkeit das auf die persische
militärmacht nicht mehr zu vertrauen war
alexander wusste ja keine von den großen
platz gestellten erobern war blond hat
im tor geöffnet zu haben die tore
geöffnet hat ihm die tore geöffnet
choral nicht wahr
hier hast du die schätze
als weltherrscher trifft alexander in
babylon ein seiner ankunft gleicht einem
triumphzug
babylon ist schon 200 jahre fest in der
hand der perser damals hat die großmacht
die schönste und größte metropole des
orients kurzerhand zu ihrem zweiten
regierungssitz ernannt
unglaublich sogar das stolze athen
erblast beim anblick bilanz größe pracht
und luxus sind nicht von dieser welt wie
es im gründungsmythos von babylon heißt
nicht könige sondern die götter selbst
haben die hacke geschwungen und die
ziegel gestrichen
bislang kennen die makedonien die
sagenhafte statt nur aus den erzählungen
ihres alten lehrers aristoteles er hat
kein gutes wort für sie übrig
alexander hingegen ist beeindruckt er
will die stadt sogar noch prächtiger
ausbauen lassen und apple in babylon
residieren wie sein vorgänger dareios
er der könig aus dem verfilmten
makedonien steht am ziel seiner träume
er hat griechenland gerecht und den sieg
gebracht sein nun ist die
alleinherrschaft über das größte reich
der welt
da ist es nicht die babylonier button
vorher wollen ihre stadt gesehen
den barbaren solche wunder vollbringen
dann will ich gern ihr könig so
[Musik]
schon bald zieht alexander über sousa
nach persepolis in der perser residenz
wartet der staatsschatz auf ihm den er
dringend braucht die kriegskasse ist
fast leer
die soldaten fordern ihren sold
[Musik]
für die meisten von ihnen ist persepolis
das ziel ihrer mission
dort soll der rachefeldzug feierlich
beendet werden wir haben uns auf dem
schlachtfeld an den fasern gerecht lasst
uns das werk vollenden mit einer fackel
du bist jetzt könig vom persie
wieso willst du deinen eigenen palast
niederbrennen
vielleicht hat er recht
was seid ihr für männer ihre frauen
dürfen wir nicht schenken und nun
versagen wir uns auch noch ein
freudenfeuer sieht so eure rache aus
also lasst es gut sein
wir haben unsere mission erfüllt wir
sollten endlich nach griechenland
zurückkehren
niemals bevor barrios nicht vor mir im
staub liegt gibt es kein zurück
all dies hier ist nichts mehr so lange
er auf freiem fuß
das gelage endet in einer katastrophe
der palast brennt fast völlig nieder was
von den flammen verschont bleibt da
wollten die soldaten
viel ist über die tat spekuliert worden
bis heute bleibt unklar ob man da im
affekt und nur aus rache gehandelt hat
[Musik]
es gibt einen in der literatur immer
übersehenen möglichen grund alexander
wollte ja nicht per se ist sondern in
babylon als hauptstadt haben
und dann waren natürlich ein zweites
zentrum ein gefahrenherd hat sich da ein
gegenpol bildet und da sagt er
schwerpunkt soll babbel und sein und
deswegen radieren wir persepolis aus
oder verschieben an die seite
wenig später ist der tag gekommen der
makedonische schickt einen großteil der
truppen zurück in die heimat
allen voran die soldaten von seinen
griechischen bündnispartnern
übrig bleiben makedonien und griechische
selber mit ihnen macht er sich auf die
suche nach darius die verfolgungsjagd
nach den perserkönig endet aber anders
als erwartet
wir haben ihn gefunden nach alexanders
siegenburger wähler hat darius nicht nur
sein weltreich verloren sondern auch
sämtliche unterstützung er wird verraten
und aus dem hinterhalt umgebracht von
den eigenen leuten ist tot
jetzt hast du was du wolltest es ist
zeit umzukehren
ein könig soll durch die hand eines
königs sterben
seine mörder stellen nicht nur seine
sondern auch meine herrschaft infrage
die müssen bestraft werden es reicht
alexander du bist könig von persien was
willst du mehr
du und dein vater ingo mehner mehr mut
bewiesen so werde es durch meine hand
gefallen
ohne uns wärst du nie so weit gekommen
macht nur weiter so dann wirst du
genauso im staub enden widerrede lässt
nämlich
es reicht keiner stellt mich in frage
weder freund noch feind
das ist nicht das erste mal dass viele
autos sich gegen mich auflebt vielhaber
diesmal ist er zu weit gegangen viele
das ist ein hitzkopf
er hat mir sogar verschwiegen dass meine
soldaten sich gegen mich stellen
jetzt weiß ich auch warum er ist der
drahtzieher hinter diesem komplott
doch das wird ihm nicht zu nutzen ich
verdiene zuvorkommen alexander wir
kennen uns seit kindertagen wir müssen
zusammenhalten sollte ich warten bis er
mich umbringt damit es gewissheit habe
er hat gedroht mich zu töten und das ist
hoferer
[Musik]
darauf steht der tod
alexander macht mit viel lotos kurzen
prozess er lässt den general und
jugendfreund brutal foltern und
hinrichten
eine warnung an alle ganz gleich ob
soldat oder engster vertrauter die
botschaft verfehlt nicht ihre wirkung
seine führungsrolle kann der makedonien
nur behaupten wenn er freundschaft und
feindschaft kalt berechnet deshalb
erhielt er eine zweite in richtung
[Musik]
dann schickt aber alexander sofort die
killer nach pattaya um auch den vater
paar millionen umzubringen
nach den regeln der damaligen zeit denn
alexander konnte und musste wissen dass
das höchste gebot in solch einem falle
die rache war der vater hätte den sohn
rechnen müssen und was der mit seinen
möglichkeiten im gesamten westen dieses
reiches hatte
das kann man sich leicht ausmalen
der tote darius wird auf anordnung von
alexander ehrenvoll bestattet er erhält
einen platz in der grablege der
persischen könige auf seinen mörder aber
wartet die todesstrafe
als alexander ins heutige afghanistan
aufbricht ist seine armee auf über
50.000 mann angewachsen darunter viele
volksgruppen aus den persern reichen
der marke braucht sie um die
widerstandsnester in den entlegenen
regionen des weltreichs auszuheben
doch die blutigen kämpfe mit den
stammesfürsten reißen nicht ab
immer wieder muss alexander niederlagen
einstecken
dann aber fällt dem feld herum eine
junge prinzessin in die hände nimmt sie
gefangen
[Musik]
es heißt alexander habe sich auf den
ersten blick in die schöne adlige
verliebt der name ist roxane kleiner
stern alexander macht sie offiziell zu
seiner frau
[Musik]
doch wie so oft geht es auch bei dieser
heirat um große politik
die aussicht auf frieden und die
gründung einer griechisch persischen
düngers team
[Musik]
diese heiraten zwischen griechen und
person hat es folien für die auch schon
gegeben aber nicht auf der königssee
und das ist also sensationell von
alexander das ja keine griechen sich als
ehefrau aussucht was er hätte tun können
und was auch erwartet worden ist
so wie sein vater in der zweiten hier
eine griechin heiratet sondern nun ganz
demonstrativ jetzt heirate ich eine
persische prinzessin dass alle leute
sehen ich bin eben der neue persische
groß könig ohne zu zögern übernimmt
alexander die persischen sitten und
gebräuche auch kusshand und kniefall
erwartet er selbst von seinen eigenen
landsleuten hinter der forderung
verbirgt sich kein größenwahn sondern
die überlegung eines machthabers
alexander muss die verachtung der perser
fürchten wenn er als ihr herrscher auf
orientalische ehren rituale verzichtet
für seine gefährten aber sind sie eine
zumutung
sie sind einen anderen umgang mit ihrem
könig gewohnt kleid aus der alexander
schon einmal das leben gerettet hat
verweigert die unterwerfungsgeste doch
aber ich kann ihn nur vergöttern
ich bin göttlicher abstammung meine
taten überstrahlen die bisher agnes und
8 und wenn du bist auch nur aus fleisch
und blut wie wir alle
wir haben seite an seite gekämpft und
gemeinsam sieg um sieg errungen
und jetzt verlangst du das hier vor dem
niederknien
ich bin der große könig ich verlange nur
den respekt der mir gebühren du
behandelst uns wie diese basischen
barbaren vergisst wer deine freunde sind
ich habe euch mehr ruhm und reichtum
beschert also je erträumt hat den ruhm
den wir alle verdient haben den willst
du jetzt für dich allein zurück und dein
gold reicht nicht aus um den respekt zu
kaufen den du mit deiner vision verloren
hast
ich hab mir sagte du schwein
ein mord aus leidenschaft geschehen
während einer der berühmt berüchtigten
trinkgelage der madonna
in einem streit um ruhm und ehre gehen
alexander und clyde haus aufeinander los
wahrscheinlich um raus
[Musik]
ich glaube dass die tötung des gleiters
in der tat eine affekthandlung war
die beiden waren sich persönlich ganz
eng verbundenen kleid aus gehörte zu den
engsten freunden und ich denke in dieser
dieser rage tötete alexander den kleid
was er dann hinterher
ernüchtert zutiefst bedauert hat aber
der mensch war tot
nur wenige wochen später scheint alles
vergessen zu sein und bald darauf ist
der herrscher schon wieder auf
erkundungstour
er hat von einem alten bergpass gehört
dennoch händler benutzen
alexander verfolgt seit langem den plan
sein imperium weiter nach osten
auszudehnen
die route soll ihn über die grenzen des
heutigen afghanistan führen
seine leute hat der marke darauf
eingeschworen ihm zu folgen auch bis ans
ende der welt dorthin wo noch kein
grieche lieber
der weg führt entlang des hindukusch
gebirges in über 1000 meter höhe
dahinter liegt ein land das noch nie
erobert wurde
weißt du noch was aristoteles uns von
diesem bergen erzählt hat als wir kinder
waren
ich erinnere mich nicht mehr
man nannte sie gipfel die kein adler
überfliegen kann
und dahinter ist das ende der welt ist
das kein grieche gesehen habe
ich gebe befehl zum abmarsch bei
tagesanbruch
gegenmittel sorgt mit den ersten pass
bezwungen haben
nach vielen blutigen kämpfen und
unfassbaren strapazen fordert alexander
das schicksal erneut heraus
spätestens dann wenn das perserreich
erobert ist allerspätestens dann kann
man sagen gut jetzt ist griechenland
gerecht aber der spannende punkt ist der
dass alexander dann nicht bremst und
dann nicht umbringt das ist den
zeitgenossen schon rätselhaft erschienen
die der meinung waren es sei fotos die
sehnsucht die alexander antriebe das
ende der damals bekannten welt
die griechen glauben es liege in indien
das exotische wunderland soll direkt an
den welt ozean stoßen der um die ganze
erde fließt
doch der globus ist viel größer ist die
antiken gelehrten immer vermutet haben
[Musik]
angeblich wagen 135000 freiwillige
soldaten den gefährlichen weg über den
khyber pass nach indien
das haupt her ist inzwischen mehr als
doppelt so groß wie zu beginn des films
[Musik]
im frühling 326 vor christus erreicht er
trotz dass indus tal im heutigen
pakistan die hitze und das feuchte klima
machen der armee schwer zu schaffen
die tierwelt ist exotisch und voller
moskitos der anhaltende monsunregen hat
den boden im undurchdringliches
marschland verwandelt die natur ist aber
nicht die einzige herausforderung
am fluss für das bis stellt sich der
indische könig boris den eindringlingen
entgegen
mit einer ebenbürtigen armee und mit
kriegsschiffen
[Musik]
das gemetzel ist blutig und steht auf
messers schneide
am ende können die eroberer aus dem
westen den sieg für sich ausmachen
es ist die letzte große schlacht die sie
schlagen
alexanders armee ist am ende ihrer
kräfte und er selbst erlebt den
schwersten verlust seines lebens wie es
heißt
[Musik]
okay war los sein geliebtes wert ist aus
erschöpfung gestorben
sein tod von alexander das herz
gebrochen haben
[Musik]
doch trotz der rückschläge will der
makedonier weiterziehen
nach acht jahren und knapp 18.000
kilometern aber haben seine männer genug
vom krieg sie malt an und wollen endlich
zurück nach griechenland
und wie hast du dich entschieden
wir sind so kurz vorm ziel ist das ende
der welt wir können es mit eigenen augen
sehen
das ist eine heldentat die keine sie
jemals übertreffen kann unseren namen
werden unsterblich sein
ich verstehe dich alexander und du weißt
ich bin dir treu gefolgt
aber ich sage dir jetzt du wirst deine
männer nicht davon abbringen können um
zu klären
sie werden sich gegen dich stellen wenn
du sie zwingst sie sterben lieber hier
durch deine hand als die ans ende der
welt zu folgen
[Musik]
und patroklos erinnerst du dich wir
wollten sein wie sie wir waren wie sie
wir haben sich sogar übertrumpft sie
beide sind im kampf gefallen das war ihr
schicksal
sie haben mich herausgefordert und was
steht uns bevor ein leben am hof umgeben
von schülern und speichellecker im
weichen schoss edler frauen-doppel
langweiligen jagdausflügen das ist es
was uns am hof bevorsteht die passion
willst du dass alexander du bist der
herrscher eines weltreichs was ist vom
rücken eines pferdes aus erobert aber du
kannst es nicht vom rücken eines pferdes
aus regieren kann sich endlich krieg
führen und wenn du das tust du dein
reich nicht von dauer sein
so kurz vor dem ziel fühlt sich
alexander im stich gelassen
doch schließlich behielt er den heimweg
[Musik]
wenn sie 70 tage lang täglich regen
haben dann haben sie keine lust mehr
weiter zu marschieren
und dann hat alexander ja diese geniale
idee das hat sich erst verschließen
seinem zelt trotz sitzstreik und dann
wieder merkt die leute geben nicht nach
werden die götter befragt und die götter
wird befragt durch die priester die
priester wissen was die götter rollen
und die priester sei schrecklich leid
könig die götter sind dagegen
da sagt alexander für die götter das
nicht ab dass ich warte dann muss ich
zurück für den rückzug wählt er
allerdings eine neue route
er selbst fährt mit einer flotte auf dem
indus bis zum indischen ozean
so hat er doch noch das ende der welt
erreicht
dann teilt er die armee die schiffe
sollen den seeweg nach persien erkunden
alexander aber nimmt mit seinem drucken
dem landweg
die soldaten müssen durch eine der
unwirtlichsten regionen der erde
der zug durch die geht russische wüste
wird zum todesmarsch als alexander
endlich ein babylon ankommt hat er mehr
männer verloren als in jeder schlacht
und die rückschläge reißen nicht ab
heißt ihn sein engster freund ist schwer
erkrankt wahrscheinlich an malaria
[Musik]
petroplus
und du bist
[Musik]
wo sowohl die starb mein freund doch
anders als in der sage ist er nicht auf
dem schlachtfeld gestorben
der gemeinsame traum vom ruhm durch den
heldentod hat sich nicht erfüllt
die trauer um seinen treuen gefährten
nimmt überwältigende ausmaße an
in babylon lässt er dreitägige leichen
spiele ausrichten so wie es auch im für
patroklos getan hat
[Musik]
kaum ein halbes jahr später erkrankt
auch alexander schweer
mitten in der vorbereitung für einen
neuen feldzug nach arabien
es gibt gerüchte dass gift im spiel sei
doch wahrscheinlich hat auch ihm das
wechselfieber befallen
der herrscher ist dem tod näher als dem
leben
[Musik]
am hof wachsen die sorgen um die zukunft
seines weltreichs
zwar trägt roxane seinen sohn unter dem
herzen aber alexander hat noch keinen
nachfolger genannt
alexander
er sollte ein imperium regieren
wichtigste und am 10 juni 323 vor
christus stirbt alexander der große über
die nachfolge bricht in griechenland ein
erbitterter streit aus das imperium das
er geschaffen hat
es fällt innerhalb weniger jahrzehnte
aber es ist ihm gelungen die griechische
kultur über drei kontinente bis nach
indien zu verbreiten
und er ist der erste europäische
weltherrscher der geschichte
sein leichnam wird in alexandria
beigesetzt in der stadt mit seinem namen
wo genau ist in vergessenheit geraten
was alexander bild vom heldenhaften
eroberer hat er maßgeblich selbst
geprägt den ehrentitel der große
verleihen ihm aber erst die römer
[Musik]
seine legende schreiben andere fort über
generationen und grenzen hinweg was
bleibt ist die faszination für einen
menschen der die welt verändert hat
[Musik]